ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, our topic
today sounds a little bit
naughty at first glance.
It's called improper
integrals.
And rather than give a long
speech about why they're
called improper, let me try and
start our lecture a little
bit different from our usual
approach, by giving you a
little bit of a mathematical
calculus riddle.
Namely, let me just say this.
We'll call our lecture today
improper integrals, and we'll
start off by saying
find the flaw.
I would like to integrate
'dx' over 'x squared'
from minus 1 to 1.
Using the first fundamental
theorem of integral calculus,
I say this is 'G of 1' minus 'G
of minus 1' where 'G prime'
is any function whose
derivative
is '1 over 'x squared''.
Well, in particular, do I know a
function whose derivative is
'1 over 'x squared''?
Well, I guess minus
'1 over x'.
In other words, the derivative
of 'x' to the minus 1 is minus
'x' to the minus 2.
With the minus in front
that makes it plus.
'x' to the minus 2.
That's plus '1 over
'x squared''.
In any event, I can then
compute that 'G
of 1' is minus 1.
'G of minus 1' is 1.
Therefore, 'G of 1' minus 'G of
minus 1' is minus 1 minus
1, is minus 2.
Therefore, the integral from
minus 1 to 1, 'dx' over 'x
squared', is minus 2.
And the question is,
find the flaw.
Find the flaw.
And since again, we're on
limited time, let me, if you
haven't already discovered the
flaw, at least point out why
you should be suspicious
of a flaw.
Remember, we visualized this
as an area under a curve.
In other words, in a way, the
base of our region is the
closed interval from minus 1
to 1, and the height of our
region at any point is given
by '1 over 'x squared''.
Well, look at '1 over
'x squared''.
Certainly, '1 over 'x squared''
can't be negative
because for any real number
'x', its square is
non-negative.
And one over a non-negative
number is certainly
non-negative.
In particular then, since my
region never goes below the
x-axis, I would expect that the
area represented by this
should be positive.
In other words, this is the sum
of positive numbers taken
in the limit.
In other words, the fact that
the integrand is non-negative
tells me that whenever the
integral turns out to be, it
must be at least as big as 0,
and minus 2 does not fulfill
that criteria.
In other words, something must
be wrong here because we get a
negative answer in a situation
where a negative answer is
preposterous.
And the reason that I wanted
to pick this approach is I
think that the best way to
motivate that something is
wrong is precisely by winding up
with a preposterous answer
in a situation where we know
the answer is preposterous.
Then we know we must be on our
guard to see what went wrong.
And what did go wrong?
Well, the key point is this.
And again, it's something that
we've said many, many times.
But I think it takes a counter
example before it
really sinks in.
People are always quoting
the first
fundamental theorem in general.
It's easy to remember that the
integral from 'a' to 'b', ''f
of x' dx' is 'G of b' minus
'G of a', where 'G
prime' equals 'f'.
But the thing that we must be
extremely careful of is that
this definition requires that
'f' be at least piecewise
continuous on the interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
Remember when we took the limit
and put the squeeze on,
we required that there be
continuity, so we could pass
to the limit.
The important point is in this
particular example that we're
dealing with, observe that '1
over 'x squared'' is infinite.
I write this in quotation marks
to point out you have a
1/0 form, which we usually
abbreviate as infinity.
In other words, '1 over 'x
squared'' increases without
bound as 'x' approaches 0.
And notice that 0 was within the
limits of our integration
from minus 1 to 1.
At any rate, without further
ado, this leads to a
fundamental definition.
Which in terms of today's
lesson, I call
definition number 1.
And that is the integral from
'a' to 'b', 'f of x dx is
called 'improper'.
And there are going to be two
types of improper integrals as
we'll find out very shortly.
But it's called improper of the
first kind, if and only if
'f' is infinite for at least one
'c' in the interval from
'a' to 'b'.
And again, let me caution you
about this and I'll summarize
at the end of the lecture
again to remind you.
If you look at this particular
integral, it doesn't look at
all suspicious.
In fact, that's where the
trap came in in this
problem over here.
The reason that we wound up with
minus 2 is that we just
integrated '1 over 'x squared'',
forgetting that
there was a point at which the
integrand was infinite in the
given interval.
And so the question that comes
up is, how shall we handle
this if we have an
infinity in here?
And the answer is, let's work
around the point at which the
integral or the integrand
is infinite.
Let's see what that means.
And this again, is a
continuation of the
definition, I guess.
If 'c' is the only point in the
closed interval from 'a'
to 'b' at which 'f' is infinite,
we defined the
integral from 'a' to 'b',
''f of x' dx' to be
the following limit.
It's the limit as
'h' approaches 0
through positive values.
The definite integral from
'a' to 'c' minus 'h'.
In other words, you're stopping
somewhere before you
get to this bad point,
evaluating ''f of x' dx'.
And there's no harm done in here
because you see, 'f of x'
is infinite only at 'x' equals
'c' in this problem.
Consequently, if you stop prior
to 'c', 'f of x' is at
least piecewise continuous
every place in here.
Then you jump over the bad
point, pick up again at 'c
plus h' and say plus the
integral from 'c plus h' to
'b', ''f of x' dx'.
This limit as 'h' approaches
0 through positive values.
Now again, this may sound
very abstract.
So to give this a more realistic
meaning to you,
let's interpret this again
in terms of an area.
What we're saying is
this pictorially.
We have a function which is
piecewise continuous at least
on the entire interval from
'a' to 'b', except at the
point 'c' where we have an
infinite discontinuity, an
infinite jump.
What we do is, is we pick a
positive number 'h' and knock
off the interval 'c minus h' to
'c plus h' surrounding 'c'.
We then compute the area.
We then compute the area
of this shaded region.
That's exactly what's inside
the brackets over here.
You see, notice that
this sum is what?
It's the sum of two integrals,
one of which names this area,
and the other of which
names this area.
And what we say is, let's put
the squeeze on and see what
limiting value this area
approaches as we squeeze all
the space out around 'c'.
In other words, what's really
happening over here?
What we're really saying is, why
can't we treat an infinite
region the same as if it were
a finite region taking the
limit as the size of the strip
in here goes to 0?
And here's the key point.
You see, as 'h' approaches 'c'
from both sides, notice that
the width of this region
approaches 0.
By the same token, the
height of the region
is approaching infinity.
In essence, what we're running
into again, is the problem of
determining the area of an
infinite region involves the
study of infinity times 0.
In fact, the question sort of
is, does 'h' go to 0 faster
than 'f of 'c plus or minus
h'' goes to infinity?
In fact, I think that's an
important enough observation,
so I've written it down
here to make sure
that you notice it.
The question centers about the
question, the problem of
whether 'h' approaches
0 faster than--
whatever this means.
Faster than 'f of 'c plus or
minus h'' approaches infinity.
In our particular example,
this didn't happen.
Now again, if you're afraid of
the symbol infinity, let's
deal with the finite case and
take the limit later.
In other words, instead of
looking at the integral from 0
to 1, 'dx' over 'x squared',
let's look at the integral
from 'h' to 1.
Integral from 'h' to 1, 'dx'
over 'x squared', and then
later we'll take the limit
as 'h' approaches 0.
In particular, if this is my
region 'R', namely bounded
above by the curve 'y' equals '1
over 'x squared'', below by
the x-axis.
On the left by the line 'x'
equals 'h' and on the right by
the line 'x' equals 1, the
area of the region 'R' is
written what?
Integral 'h' to 1, 'dx'
over 'x squared'.
Notice that as long as 'h' is
not 0, our integrand is
continuous.
Therefore, we can use the first
fundamental theorem to
evaluate it.
It's what?
It's minus '1 over x' evaluated
between 'h' and 1.
Putting in the upper limit
gives me a minus 1.
Putting in the lower limit
gives me minus '1/h'.
But I'm subtracting that, so
it becomes plus '1/h'.
In other words, the area of my
region 'R' is 1/h minus 1.
Notice then that 'A sub R' as
'h' approaches 0 from the
right becomes the limit of '1/h'
as 'h' approaches 0 from
the right minus 1.
And the limit of '1/h' as 'h'
approaches 0 from the right is
clearly infinity.
In other words, as 'h' gets
arbitrarily close to 0 through
positive values, '1/h' increases
without any bound.
In other words, what this means
in plain English is that
we can make the area of the
region 'R' as arbitrarily as
large as we wish just by
choosing 'h' to be
sufficiently close to 0 here.
You see, in other words, as
'h' approaches 0, what's
happening here is that this
curve is not approaching the
y-axis fast enough to allow
us to get a finite area.
And by the way, let me make
one little aside comparing
this with our previous answer.
You may recall, and let me just
pull this board down here
to remind you of that.
You may recall that when we
worked this problem before, we
got the wrong answer,
negative 2.
OK, now look it.
In terms of my problem over
here, we went from minus 1 to
1 so this is only 1/2
of the region that
we're talking about.
Notice that the minus
2 comes from this.
See twice minus 1 by symmetry.
The interesting thing is notice
here that when you take
the limit--
well, forgetting that there's
an infinite discontinuity
here, when you let 'h' approach
0, you tend to say
let's forget about the function
of 'h' in here.
Notice here as 'h' approaches
0, this
thing went to infinity.
By ignoring it, that's where
you got the answer minus 2.
In other words, by assuming
that as 'h' got small, the
function of 'h' got small, we
threw out an infinite part of
our answer.
In other words, this was
the thing that we
had to worry about.
In this particular case, we
slurred over something that
wasn't going to 0 fast enough.
By the way, let me caution you
and point out that in this
particular example it happened
that infinity
times 0 became infinite.
It is possible, however, that
as 'h' approaches 0, it may
happen that 'h' approaches 0
fast enough, so that we do get
a finite area.
To show you this, let's just
change the problem slightly.
Instead of taking 'y' equals
'1 over 'x squared'', let's
take 'y' equals '1 over the
'square root of x''.
The same problem, and by the
way, here's the subtlety of
this again.
If you were to sketch 'y' equals
'1 over the 'square
root of x'' alongside of 'y'
equals '1 over 'x squared''--
in fact, fast enough so that
even though we get an infinite
region, it has only
a finite area.
In particular, here's
what I'm saying now.
Let 'R' be the region bounded
above by 'y' equals '1 over
the 'square root of x',
below by the x-axis.
On the left by 'x' equals
'h' and on the right
by 'x' equals 1.
Again, since the only place that
'1 over the 'square root
of x'' has an infinite
discontinuity is when 'x' is
0, and since 'h' is greater
than 0 here, we have a
continuous integrand.
The area of the region 'R'
therefore is given by what?
Any function whose derivative is
'1 over the 'square root of
x'' evaluated between
'h' and 1.
Again, sparing you
the details.
Observe that if you
differentiate twice 'x to the
1/2', the 1/2 and the 2 cancel
and you get '1 over the
'square root of x''.
In other words, 2 square root
of 'x' is the function whose
derivative is '1 over the
'square root of x''.
If I now evaluate that between
1 and 'h', I get 2 minus 2
'square root of h'.
If I now take the limit of 'A
sub R' as 'h' approaches 0,
notice that what happens here
is that as 'h' approaches 0,
so does the square
root of 'h'.
And the area turns out
to be 2 in the limit.
In other words, the area of
the region 'R' in this
particular case, is also
a function of 'h'.
But the part that depends
on 'h' goes to 0
as 'h' goes to 0.
In fact, notice in this
particular case, and why I
couldn't have started with this
example is that if I took
this example and you did it the
incorrect way, in other
words, if you failed to notice
that '1 over the 'square root
of x'' was discontinuous at 'x'
equals 0, and you just did
this problem mechanically, and
evaluated this between 0 and
1, you would have got
the right answer.
And the reason that you would
have got the right answer, is
that in the limit process,
notice here that the part of
the answer that depends
on 'h' does actually
go to 0 in the limit.
At any rate, using all of this
as motivation, we come to a
new piece of terminology
that we should define.
Namely, if 'f' is infinite at
'x' equals 'c', where 'c' is
someplace in the interval from
'a' to 'b', then the improper
integral 'a' to 'b', ''f of x'
dx' is called convergent if
the particular limit that we
talked about previously in the
definition of how you compute
integral from 'a' to 'b', ''f
of x' dx', if that particular
limit exists, meaning it's a
finite number, then we call
the integral a convergent
improper integral.
On the other hand,
meaning what?
If this limit doesn't exist, if
for example, the limit is
infinite, then we call the
integral divergent.
In other words, in our
first example, the
integral was divergent.
In the second example, the
integral was convergent.
By the way, it's rather
interesting to point out too--
I shouldn't say it's
rather interesting.
It's just my excuse of I don't
know of any other way of
motivating improper integrals
of the second kind.
But the thing that's worth
observing is this.
When we evaluated the area under
the curve here from 0 to
1, we elected to pick
strips like this.
Remember this is why we
got into that infinite
discontinuity; we picked out
strips to look like this.
The question that comes up is,
why couldn't we have picked
our strips to be horizontal?
In other words, if we had
in terms of say, inverse
functions, inverted the role of
'x' and 'y', why couldn't
we have computed our area by
picking strips like this and
adding them all up from 1 to
'b', and then taking the limit
as 'b' went to infinity?
In other words, if I wanted to
compute the area of this
region using horizontal strips,
I would have had what?
I would have had the area of the
region 'R' is the integral
from 1 to 'b'.
And remember, if 'y' equals '1
over 'x squared'', 'x' is '1
over the 'square root of y''.
Therefore, the area of the
region 'R' is the interval
from 1 to 'b', 'dy' over
the square root of 'y'.
Notice that the square root of
'y' is certainly continuous.
'1 over the 'square
root of y'' is
continuous in this interval.
At any rate, I could then have
evaluated this integrand here
and taken the limit as 'b'
approached infinity.
And by the way, the abbreviation
for writing the
limit of the integral 1 to 'b'
as 'b' approaches infinity, is
to simply write integral from
1 to infinity 'dy' over the
square root of 'y'.
And this is all this
thing means.
For example, in this particular
case, notice that
as 'b' goes to infinity, so does
the square root of 'b'.
Therefore, 2 'square root of b'
minus 2 goes to infinity as
'b' approaches infinity.
And we find by a second method
that the area of
our region is infinite.
And again, we have another kind
of improper integral.
But structurally, this
improper integral is
completely different
from the improper
integral that we had before.
Namely, before we had an
improper integral where the
integrand became infinite,
even though the limits of
integration stayed finite.
Notice what happens
in this case.
In this particular case, notice
that the integrand
stays finite.
It's the limits of integration
that become infinite.
In other words, this leads to
our next definition of a new
type of improper integral.
Namely, the integral say, from
'a' to infinity ''f of x' dx'.
Whereby this we mean the
abbreviation limit as 'b'
approaches infinity, integral
from 'a' to 'b', ''f of x'
dx', where 'f' is continuous
in this entire range.
In other words, for 'x' greater
than or equal to 'a'.
That type of an integral is
called an improper integral of
the second kind.
In other words, in the first
kind, the integrand becomes
infinite, but the limits of
integration are finite.
In the second kind, the
integrand stays finite, but
the limits of integration take
on an infinite range.
And the important point is
that these two are very
closely connected.
In other words, in terms of the
example that I just showed
you, I wanted you to see how you
can get from an integral
of the first kind to an improper
integral of the
second kind just by replacing
your vertical strips by
horizontal strips.
In fact, in terms of my first
example over here notice that
indeed, '1 over 'x squared'' and
'1 over the 'square root
of x'', where 'x' is at least
as big as 0, are inverses.
By the way, the reason I say 'x'
is, in fact, bigger than
0, otherwise I'll have
a 0 denominator here.
The reason I point this out is
that if you don't presuppose
that x is positive, remember,
the square root function or
the squaring function is not
1:1, so I have to be very
careful when I talk about
inverse functions.
The thing I want to see however
is, the graph of 'y'
equals '1 over 'x squared'' is
the inverse of the graph 'y'
equals '1 over the 'square
root of x''.
In other words, essentially, by
interchanging the role of
the x- and y-axes, you go from
one graph to the other.
You see, in particular, the
integral 1 to infinity, 'dx'
over 'x squared'.
Namely, finding the area of this
particular region is the
inverse of finding the area
of this particular region.
In other words, notice that
'y' equals '1 over 'x
squared'' behaves for large
values of 'x' the same as 'y'
equals '1 over the 'square root
of x'' behaves for small
parts of the values of 'x'.
Again, let me point out that
much of this will be done much
more hard core in our learning
exercises and in the reading
material and the like.
And so I pass over some of this
in a fairly quick way.
But what I want to make sure is
clear before we begin the
exercises and the reading
material is that we have a
good idea as to what improper
integrals mean.
At any rate, continuing on this
way, what do I mean by
the integral from
1 to infinity,
'dx' over 'x squared'?
Well, it's an improper integral
of a second type
because the integrand is finite
between 1 and infinity.
The limits of integration span
an infinite space over here.
At any rate, it's what?
The limit as 'b' approaches
infinity, integral from 1 to
'b', 'dx' over 'x squared'.
At any rate, what
is the integral
of '1 over 'x squared''.
It's minus '1/x'.
If I evaluate that that's minus
''1 over b' plus 1'.
And if I now take the limit as
'b' approaches infinity that
answer is 1.
In other words, what this means
pictorially is the following.
If I look at the area of this
region 'R' for any value of
'b' whatsoever, that area is
equal to 1 minus '1/b'.
In other words, no matter how
big 'b' becomes, the area of
this region 'R' can never
be as big as one unit.
And in the limit, as 'b' goes
out as far as we wish, what
we're really saying is what?
That the area of this region
'R' can be made arbitrarily
close to 1 just by choosing 'b'
to be arbitrarily large.
And by the way, this you see
leads to an interesting
observation.
Namely, at this end of the
spectrum, the curve was not
approaching the y-axis
fast enough to make
this integral finite.
Remember, the integral from 0
to 1, 'dx' over 'x squared'
was infinite.
However, for large values of
'x', the curve does approach
the x-axis fast enough, so that
not only is the enclosed
area finite, it can't even
be bigger than 1.
I thought that might be an
interesting example for you to
think about for a while.
Another type of interesting
example worth thinking about
for a while is this
second example.
Let's take the region 'R' to be
bounded above by 'y' equals
'1/x', on the left by 'x' equals
1, on the right by 'x'
equals 'b', and below
by the x-axis.
And let's compute the area
of the region 'R'.
Again, the area of the region
'R' is a definite integral
from 1 to 'b', 'dx' over 'x'.
And that's equal to the
natural log of 'b'.
Namely, this integral is log
absolute value of 'x'.
Log absolute value of
'b' is just 'log b'.
Log 1 is 0.
So the area of the region
'R' is 'log b'.
As 'b' increases without bound,
its log increases
without bound, we find
that the area of the
region 'R' is infinite.
In fact, another way of
saying this is what?
This is the integral 1 to
infinity 'dx' over 'x'.
And this is, therefore, what?
A divergent improper integral
of the second type.
All right, so far so
good at any rate.
Let me review our volumes of
revolution and rotation.
Let's take the region 'R' and
rotate it about the x-axis.
If we rotate 'R' about the
x-axis, remember a volume of
revolution is just pi 'y
squared' 'dx' from 1 to 'b'.
Well, my 'y' is '1/x'.
That's '1 over x squared'.
The integral of '1 over x
squared' is minus '1/x'.
Notice then as before, the
volume when I rotate 'R' about
the x-axis is just pi times
'1 minus '1/b''.
In other words, what this say
is as 'b' gets very, very
large, so does 'R'.
Yet, if I rotate 'R' about the
x-axis, no matter how big 'b'
is the volume is just pi
times '1 minus '1/b''.
As 'b' approaches infinity, this
goes to 0 and my volume
is just pi.
In other words, this area
gets infinitely large.
Yet, the volume generated
by rotating that
area remains finite.
Again, another idiosyncrasy
of working with improper
integrals and infinite
regions.
You've got to be very, very
careful about how rapidly
something approaches 0 or
infinity because infinity
times 0 is indeterminate.
In other words, here is a very
important observation, an
infinite area can enclose or can
generate a finite volume.
Be very, very careful
in dealing
with improper integrals.
And by the way, let me make
one computational aside.
In trying to determine whether a
particular improper integral
is convergent or not, we do not
have to be able to compute
the limit itself.
I mention this because
it's very important.
Sometime you'll be given an
integral which you don't know
how to integrate directly.
A typical example that usually
comes up, integral ''e to the
minus 'x squared' dx', say
between 1 and infinity.
And you want to know whether
this converges or not.
You don't care what the limit
is because once you know it
converges, you can approximate
it to as great a degree of
accuracy as you wish.
So the question is, does this
converge or doesn't it?
And again, the answer is, let's
see what happens on this
particular range, for example.
In other words, we know, for
example, that if 'x' is
greater than or equal to 1 for
numbers in magnitude at least
as big as 1, the square
exceeds the number.
In particular by the way, if 'x
squared' exceeds 'x', minus
'x squared' cannot
exceed minus 'x'.
In other words, on this
particular interval that we're
dealing with, say from 1 to
'b', as 'b' approaches
infinity, 'e to the minus
'x squared'' is
less than minus 'x'.
Therefore, because the
exponential function is 1:1,
''e to the minus 'x squared'
dx' from 1 to 'b' cannot
exceed the integral from 1 to
'b', ''e to the minus x' dx'.
In other words, since this
exponent is less than this
exponent, this integral
is less than this one.
However, it turns out that we
know how to evaluate this one.
How do we integrate 'e
to the minus x'?
It's just minus 'e
to the minus x'.
And if we evaluate that between
1 and 'b', we find
that we get '1/e' minus '1
over 'e to the b'' power.
'b' is some positive number.
This thing here is less
than infinity.
In fact, as 'b' approaches
infinity, this approaches 0,
and the limiting
value is '1/e'.
In other words, what we now know
is, is that whatever this
improper integral is, it cannot
exceed '1/e' even
though we don't know what
the exact answer is.
Pictorially, you see what
happens over here is that the
curve which I've drawn in the
accentuated chalk, this curve
is 'y' equals 'e to the
minus 'x squared''.
The light curve is 'y' equals
'e to the minus x'.
Notice that these two curves
crisscross when 'x' equals 1.
And all we're saying is that
since the white curve chops
off a finite area and the
accentuated curve, the dark
curve is inside the white one,
certainly the area enclosed by
the black curve cannot exceed
that of the white curve.
In other words, if this region
here approaches a finite value
as 'x' goes to infinity, so
must the other region.
And this is essentially
the theory
behind improper integrals.
In closing, there is one
thing I would like
to say about this.
It's a short summary, but
here's the whole idea.
It may be difficult to evaluate
improper integrals of
a second kind.
But in the certain manner of
speaking, they're not dangerous.
In what manner of speaking?
Well, when you see the limits on
the integral sign like a to
infinity, or minus infinity to
'b', or minus infinity to
infinity, you're
on the lookout.
You're on the lookout
to be careful about
something going wrong.
There's something about the
symbol infinity, which
hopefully strikes a certain fear
or respect in your minds
when you work mathematically.
See, we have a warning to
be ware in this case.
However, the dangerous part is
that when you're given an
improper integral of the first
type, and I don't know the
best way of saying this other
than to say perhaps, that
mathematics has no built-in
burglar alarms.
What I mean by that is if you're
supposed to multiply 5
and 3 to get the right answer to
a problem, and instead you
add 5 and 3, you're going to
get 8 for the answer even
though it's incorrect.
There's not going to be a buzzer
that goes off and says,
please do not add these
two numbers.
In other words, if you go ahead
over here and you forget
that 'f of x' may be infinite
and you go ahead and integrate
this using the first fundamental
theorem, you're
going to get an answer just like
we did in our beginning
exercise at the beginning
of the lecture.
It happened to be the
wrong answer.
So in other words, the word of
warning here is whenever you
see an integral with finite
limits of integration, check
the integrand and make sure it
doesn't blow up, it doesn't
become infinite.
At any rate, with these words
we finish our block on
integration.
And until next time, good bye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.